by the way you know what other song you
love that I you love King Crimson don't
you oh so good care cord of the Crimson
King oh my good God that band can I do
that for you I'd like to they just out
of their minds check this out you're
going to be
[Music]
impressed what do you think it's perfect
brilliant right I listen to best part
was your expression that's the part that
made me the happy is you said that
Robert Frip plays the guitar with his
hand spread out and that inspired you
what do you mean by a guitar player who
plays with his hands spread out can you
show me that no I was just jealous and
it's because he uses these funny tunings
he probably would look at my guitar
playing and saying you're a but um
but but he does these great he has this
weird tuning so that he ends up playing
in this very sort of formal way but and
then makes all those crazy noises but he
plays kind of like this and then I've
there's quite a few you know I'll play
something and I'll show Tim or some
other guitar Tim Reynolds or some other
guitar players I'll show them what I'm
doing and then they go oh you could just
do it like this and they do the have to
spread your you don't have to spread
your whole hand out but it makes a sound
and it and it it lets me like if it's if
was like like satellite or something
like that would go which is one of our
songs sorry but it goes like yeah yeah
but it so it's it's this it's like a
pattern but it was from watching him and
it doesn't sound the same as a Robert
rip thing but but the way but I
understand your hand is spread out
across those Frets very wide it looks
very difficult to Hold Your Hand like
that through a song that's kind of
satisfied and then you you can make
these patterns up and just sort of
repeat the patterns I did it on this
another song called Warehouse where
I but I don't need to do there's
probably an easier way to play it but
it's sort of satisfying to and and
anyway I was just trying to imitate him
and I was also ignorant so the
combination of those two things maybe
like I was trying to play what he was
playing but by looking at him rather
than listening which is a lot of
musicians play things by listening to
them but I just like what is he doing
and then I try and do it and I go oh
that's nice and it didn't sound anything
like he what he was doing but it was it
was
nice